du côté diplomatique emmanuel macron lui
se rend visite à moscou la semaine
prochaine il y rencontrera vladimir
poutine le président français qui doit
aussi se rendre à kiev pour rencontrer
ensuite le président céline ce qui on en
parle avec vous caroline de camaret
bonjour vous êtes notre spécialiste des
questions européennes ici à france 24
c'est donc un retour sur la scène
européenne concernant le dossier
ukrainien pour emmanuel macron est ce
que les européens sont un peu trop
absents sur ce dossier en fait c'est la
dîme hercule team qui est clairement
avait l'intention de jouer le match au
dessus de leur tête directement en
négociant avec joe biden il était à bon
niveau pour lui et donc l'otan avait du
coup retrouvé toutes ses couleurs d'
alliance atlantique de 30 membres
capables dans le retour de las de la
guerre froide de nous défendre contre ce
vladimir poutine c'est ce que nous dit
un peu d'ailleurs son secrétaire général
adjoint mircea geoana que j'ai
interviewé je vous invite à écouter
ne connaissant pas les intentions du
président poutine dont nous sommes
inquiets
et pour ça nous nous prenons des mesures
de vigilance de prudence
en escale à driss de notre part est ce
que nous faisons que la france fait en
roumanie dans mon pays d'origine
ce que les autres alliés font peau pour
les autres nous avons envoyé à la partie
russe nos propositions écrites il y a il
y a quelques jours nous attendons
toujours le la réponse de la part de
crémines je vois une concertation
impeccable entre l'otan et l'union
européenne ce que nous voyons ce sont
les démarches que la france et
l'allemagne je crois que les deux pays
le chancelier le président de la
république ils ont en effet une
obligation de réactiver le format
normandie donc c'est bien alors c'est
bien vous avez compris effectivement
l'otan ne veut pas entendre parler d'un
vladimir poutine qui choisiraient et des
membres qui ont le droit ou non
d'adhérer à l'alliance atlantique
typiquement l'ukraine serait dans son
pré carré il faut pas y toucher et c'est
bien qu'ils aient ces initiatives
diplomatiques de type format normandie
france allemagne ukraine russie qui se
remettent en branle pour évidemment et
éviter à l'otan en particulier un
conflit armé direct alors lui emmanuel
macron il espère donc trouver une
solution relancer les discussions lors
de son voyage la semaine prochaine est
ce qu il a des chances d'obtenir des
avancées diplomatiques alors c'est une
double visite effectivement vous l'avais
dit à moscou donc lundi avec la dîmière
poutine il s'est déjà rendu la balle a
déjà rencontré effectivement plusieurs
fois un
l'admirent poutine et
inversement il n'avait jamais été à kiev
et il y va mardi le lendemain donc pour
la première fois pour plaider pour une
désescalade sur l'armement alors que
d'admir poutine voudrais clarifier le
sort des dd république indépendantiste
et puis emmanuel macron lui il va
insister sur un nouvel équilibre un
nouvel ordre de sécurité en europe autre
sujet que vladimir poutine refuse
d'aborder bref il ya toujours un danger
a finalement parler dialoguer avec ceux
vladimir poutine qui est quand même
qui finalement à des initiatives à ces
malheureux surtout quand certaines
personnes en particulier le haut
représentant en a fait les frais se
trouve sur sur son sol et qu'il a
tendance à créer encore plus de tension
emmanuel macron il voudrait bien
réitérer l'exploit de nicolas sarkozy en
2008 qui était à la tête de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne et qui alors s'était
rendu en géorgie pour arrêter la guerre
est gelé le conflit en tant que tel
simplement il n'a pas la même place dans
les traités parce que cette présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne ya un président permanent qui
s'appelle charles michel il ya un
représentant maintenant qui a été créé
les choses ont évolué les choses ont
évolué et puis il a des moyens un peu
limité aussi alors ce sont les sanctions
économiques eux déployés les européens
qui ont un certain impact effectivement
qui appauvrissent la russie et les
proches de la demi-heure poutine ça
c'est une bonne chose mais il ya un
autre un autre acteur majeur qui est
maintenant le nouveau chancelier olafsen
social démocrate qui lui a entre les
mains une autre arme de guerre qui est
coupée cette mise en fonction de nord
stream le fameux pipeline qui de la rue
s'ils contournent l'ukraine et arrivent
jusqu'au sol de l'allemagne et des pays
européens
et ça effectivement c'est pour ça que
dans une deuxième couche après la visite
de les manuels mâcon ce sera au tour du
chancelier allemand d'aller vers poutine
et on espère peut-être réussir à nouveau
un format a4